as inside Putin's Russia the stop from
the Carnegie Endowment for international
peace in Washington DC is an hour 10
minutes good morning ladies and
gentlemen my name is Andres auslan and
I'm director of Russian and Eurasian
program here at the Carnegie Endowment
for international peace for me today
this is a great honor and a pleasure a
Andrew junk has written this wonderful
book if anybody hasn't bought it already
we have sales of it outside inside
Putin's Russia can there be reform
without democracy and I would say that
this is a classical Moscow correspondent
book about Russia that brings up the
main theme of what had happened in
Russia in the last six years I've read
it carefully and it's a good read it's
something that you can really enjoy and
I'll give you a few comments afterwards
because our intended commentator mark
marriage his wife happened to had a baby
early this morning so here for
explicable reasons he can't come and
energetic has been be excellent bureau
chief of the Financial Times for the
last few years he has worked in Moscow
for Financial Times since 1998 and he
has really learned a lot about the place
and during his years there I've found
him by launch the best-informed
the journalists in Moscow and a person
with an excellent judgment so please
Andrew give us a few points about what
to think about Russia today connection
we evoke the cordial
thanks very much
Anders follow that I'm especially steady
here and thinking about the development
of this book which I wrote over the past
year year and a half it reminded me a
bit of that some soviet-era story about
the dissident who hands out samizdat in
Red Square until he gets some arrested
by the KGB and dragged off to Lubyanka
and then finally they sort of get down
to looking at the details of the case
and they look at the brochure that he
was handing out and it's just two blank
pieces of paper and they say well what's
all this about and he says well
everybody knows what the problem is
there's no point in writing it down and
it seems to me today the sort of the
contrast is the opposite effectively you
can pretty much say whatever you like at
least in print form with oh not always
necessarily these days on the broadcast
media in Russia but no-one these days
really agrees on what the problem is or
exactly where the balances we were
saying just before this between the the
glass half full or half empty lies but
if I was forced to categorize Putin or
Putin's regime in in a very simple label
I would call it crudely liberals
authoritarianism or if you like liberal
check ISM of sorts which is to say on
the one hand Putin in terms of economic
reform in particular is essentially
market oriented he's a liberal reformer
perhaps not genetically if you like but
at the very least pragmatically because
he's recognized from his own background
and upbringing and his own experiences
in the Soviet the late Soviet and the
post-soviet times that to achieve the
sort of broad strategic goal that he has
of restoring Russia's greatness in the
world probably economic growth through
encouraging of investment and
restructuring through maintaining the
legacy that was begun in the late
eighties and particularly in the early
90s is the only real way forward and
clearly that the planned economy in
large broad terms has no future
but on the other hand there's no doubt
that Putin in many ways is authoritarian
that's clearly not surprising
his background both given the man who by
his own admission knocked on the door of
the local headquarters of the KGB in
Leningrad and asked to be recruited aid
simply 16 somebody who joined the
organization just of course when Yuri
Andropov was taking over in charge of it
and then somebody of course in
post-soviet times for whom his first and
foremost mentor was Anatoly Sobchak who
while a great rhetorician and
anti-communist as it were and arguer
intellectually for democratic principles
I think clearly if you talk to anyone
who worked in Leningrad San Petersburg
in the early 90s would argue that his
personal leadership style was actually
very autocratic and similarly in the
second half of the 90s not necessarily a
mentor but nonetheless Putin's political
boss of course was Boris Yeltsin again
democratic principles on the one hand
but the realities including his own
personal style very mercurial and quite
authoritarian on the other and so in
many ways I see printed as something of
a continuation of that tradition coming
to perhaps where we are today and
particularly the second route in term
and post bisland and so on I would still
stick to that moniker liberal
authoritarianism but I would perhaps say
a little bit less liberal and a little
bit more authoritarian that said I think
clearly sometimes commentary
particularly in the West can tend to
veer too quickly into caricature and
fail to understand the complexities
within which Putin has to operate the
legacy of the late Soviet period the
chaos of the 1990s the very strong
vested interests the need for him to
create a new identity and separate
himself from those influences that put
him into power but I think you know for
example pick two examples to just talk
about that idea of limited margin of
manoeuvre I would take for example
Chechnya where of course the very often
you hear the demand in the West for
opening negotiations with Mossad off but
clearly the
Jia's must hold off if he was even
something of a moderately effective
political leader in 97 them very quickly
his authority and ability to rule the
country and to bring it back to some
sort of order failed and so certainly by
today five years after the beginning of
the second chechen war it's hard to
imagine Mahadev could effectively be a
credible leader of the Republic but
happy to come back and discuss that more
in detail but all that to say simply
that if once to criticize the failures
of Putin's policy in Chechnya today and
there are some very concrete things that
I would criticize about it on the other
hand I think we must absolutely not
forget both the legacy of the Yeltsin
years and indeed the Stalin era in
creating a lot of these problems in the
first place but also a reminder of the
very weak instruments of State and of
individual departments the security
services and in the military in
particular which Putin is not
necessarily fully able to control or
manage as he might himself want a second
example would be NTV if we're talking
about Putin's attack on the media
there's no doubt one of the most
depressing things looking at Russia
today compared with five years ago is
that that diversity of opinion and
criticism in Russia particularly on the
national electronic media has
objectively reduced but I would say
again sometimes the the outputs that
we've seen of Putin's policy don't
necessarily correspond to the desired
inputs and if I think back to the NTV
saga in particular I would say that
while there was no doubt Putin's
tactical objective was the removal of
Vladimir Gusinsky as the controlling
agents behind NTV a station which I
certainly wouldn't describe as
independent or objective but did at
least express a different form of views
than those propagated by the Kremlin or
the Yeltsin circle the fact is the
outcome that we had the outcome that we
have today with Gazprom and a rather a
paid group of other shareholders from
some petersburg controlling the company
is not necessarily the one
that Putin himself might have wished and
is a reminder of the very strong
corporate and political and personal
vested interests that very often come to
play in Russia and it's also and we can
come back to this again but symptomatic
in the Yukos case of the failures and
inefficiencies and weaknesses still of
the Soviet and post legacy Soviet
post-soviet legacy in the police service
in the prosecutor's office in the tax
authorities and in the courts we saw
that with NTV we've seen it with you
costs will see it no doubt in many other
ways in the future so how does post
Aslan Russia look I mean it seems to me
that clearly was a defining moment much
more and it's expected and radical in
many ways than Putin's re-election which
was very much of course for drawn
conclusion already many months ago by
the time all significant potential
political opponents had been removed in
even those with some margins degree of
influence or ability to challenge his
overwhelming victory were pushed fairly
ruthlessly to one side I receive Aslan
certainly as suggesting clearly a
considerable degree of democratic
backsliding the Russians of course would
would argue that a move towards the
appointment of governors or indeed
appointment of judges let alone the
removal of this very strange hybrid
Dumas half proportional representation
half single mandate seats is something
that's not exceptional in many other
parts of the world and therefore the
criticism of these reforms is
exaggerated all I would say was that it
seems to me in the Russian context there
were at least some moves towards
fledgling greater accountability and
transparency in governance and some very
very modest attempts at a sort of
counterbalancing power and the danger in
the Russian context of these post
bisland democratic reforms is
essentially to still further resent
relize power in a way that if the even
if the enlightened objective might be
more effective implementation of
enlightened rule
one of course that depends on how
enlightened that rule is and two it
depends on how effectively it'll be
implemented and it seems to me the
danger is that we end up creating a
system that will be much more based on
personal loyalties than it will
necessarily on the basis of competence
amongst those in the regions and
elsewhere who are appointed by this new
system I think overall it seems to me I
would analyze quite a lot of Putin's
approach to governing over the past few
years as being more or less right
analysis more or less wrong solution and
it seems to me that if you look at for
example the whole style of managing his
officials local politicians and so on
it's an approach based on a rather
Soviet or even Asian idea of what you
might call management by compromise
essentially have information on people
tolerate corrupt corruption as a way
then to subsequently manipulate them
it's a well-established tradition and
arguably in that culture it may be one
that works but it clearly is the
antithesis of any approach that focuses
on a gain transparency or accountability
holding top officials responsible for
what they've done
Putin seems to me to be recreating a
sort of late Soviet or sort of
long-standing Soviet tradition
essentially of rotating colleges but
never removing them from the system in
the way that Gorbachev began to do for
example and I think while there may be
some attractions to recreating the best
of the non ideological aspects of the
Soviets structures of management I think
this approach of management by comprar
compromise and of focusing on loyalty
over competence is a very worrying one
as I say arguably perhaps in the Russian
context there is no choice certainly it
seems to me that it's not in Putin's own
background to take an alternative view
but I must say I was quite struck again
we can debate this but I was just in
Georgia and the rest of the south
caucuses a couple of weeks ago and I had
been continued to be quite skeptical of
a lot of aspects of
saakashvili's rule but I have to say the
attempts that he's made in the first few
months to remove the old guard not
simply in some symbolic ministries such
as you know economics or investment but
in the defense and the interior ministry
and so on to fire large numbers of
officials to put senior ministers into
prison or to demand substantial
multi-million dollar reimbursements and
then to start moving down the hierarchy
of governance and employed appoint a
whole series of younger very often
Western educated more outward looking
individuals into positions from minister
to Vice Minister to governor to assisted
governor and so on does at least offer a
rather interesting and perhaps
optimistic potential alternative model
albeit on a much school of smaller scale
in Georgia and in a culture that clearly
is very different so what do I see
looking forward as I said I think
further backsliding I think Putin isn't
necessarily genetically opposed to
democracy but the view is certainly
democratic processes are for later we're
in a period of transition and while that
goes on we must implement with tightly
controlled centralized structures
unfortunately I have to say I've not
been too impressed by the quality of a
number of those that he has chosen or is
needed to rely on to implement that new
project and the danger of course in the
longer term is that this is creating in
many ways a more personalized form of
governance which represents for me a
setback from any attempt to try to
create something like independent more
institutionalized governance with a more
attempt to create rule of law principles
rather than personalities as the the key
factor in terms of the economy itself we
could talk again about this in
discussions and clearly there are some
worrying trends in terms of the lack of
diversification of the economy away from
oil the complacency that 50-dollar oil
has caused in officials the slowdown of
a whole series of structural reforms I
have to say still though I do see
considerable underlying dynamism
the Russian economy partly as a result
of trickle-down but also as a result of
a lot of those post Soviets
restructurings the advantages of
privatization that took place alongside
unfortunately the very negative social
consequences that created such problems
for the Reformers to push through those
initiatives in the 90s and I see much
less initiative precisely on that area
of trying to concretely tackle the
issues of property and social division
the failures of the education and the
health system and so on in Russia that
really do need to be a substantial point
of attention if we're to see Russia
moving towards a more effective and
modernized state but as I say I think
clearly with economic growth still at
more than 7% a year clearly with not
just Moscow but an enormous number of
towns and settlements across Russia
benefiting from reduction of wage
arrears wage increases pensions
increases and so on the prospects in
purely economic terms certainly look
much better than they have done for an
awful long time for Russia the problem
the challenge at least it seems to me is
just simply that's not being accompanied
by a broader democratic debate and I see
a slightly worrying resurgence of
nationalism and pride in Russia perhaps
a little bit too soon and so I think as
we move towards 2008 we're not
necessarily going to see any vast
contradiction between the sort of the
liberal and the thought authoritarian
axes that I've talked about but I think
we could well look back at the very
least and talk about a period of missed
opportunities when so much more could
have been done to try and create some
green shoots both in economic policy
terms and particularly in terms of those
broader issues of society and I think
clearly as we come towards the question
of succession which we might discuss
later again the danger as I say is that
Putin does bequeath if he leaves at all
a nation which is still far too based on
personal manifestations of power than a
state that looks a little bit more able
to
progress through solid institutions that
we can rely on and use as the basis for
prediction thank you thank you very much
and I think that this was quite an
interesting presentation of world
Putin's Russia has become today I would
say that this book is the belongs to
this group of classical books of Moscow
correspondents book I'm thinking of
Robert Kai's as Russia and headaches mr.
Russians and David Remnick Lenin stove I
think the best books from post
journalistic book from the post-soviet
period had been Chrystia Freeland the
sale of a century
David Hoffman's it the oligarchs and
this I think is the first substantial
Moscow correspondent book on Putin's
Russia it provides a full-fledged
picture it's I would say about the seven
main themes as and represented here are
Putin's rise to power his character with
the war in Chechnya how he defeated the
oligarchs his market oriented economic
reforms his authoritarianism and then
it's quite successful the foreign policy
a difference with obvious book in
comparison with previous Moscow
correspondents book is that Android has
actually written the whole book while
being on post in Moscow which said
something about how the news flow has
slowed down in comparison with what it
was in the previous 15 years or so I get
the robbery character and Hedrick Smith
could calmly write the books while them
on post and
this is a very good and broadly to
chebet we are referring to the the
observation in the book that I found
most chilling and telling that is when
Andrew interviews one of the Putin's
former teachers in st. Petersburg and
she says that young Vladimir always had
a picture of Alex tagines here on his
wall as a boy I mean what kind of
character space that sort of got me
convinced about certain fundamentals but
unless the wave here is two questions
that I would you're dealing with them in
the book but the countless you can't
quite provide the full answer to them
because the evidence isn't there but one
is how corrupt is the current Kremlin
I'm not necessarily saying mr. Putin but
the Kremlin as such if if you talk now
to the Moscow elite you hear a common
view I thought that the corruption could
never become as bad as it was in jail
since time but now it's worse this is
something that you hear quite all
friendly often and of course this is
very difficult to write about it's very
difficult to quantify but if you look up
on the preconditions for corruption
today at the top of the Russian society
there of course I did you have oil that
provides ample rents these rents can
easily be transferred from one private
estate company to some private pocket
there are new checks and balances and
there's no transparency it would be
quite extraordinary
if corruption did not
flourish under these conditions and you
touch upon it in the book but it would
be interesting to see if you could
elaborate a bit more upon it
you discussed the quantum Hall solitaire
and Putin Russia has become and of
course was a consensus view that his
regime is becoming more authoritarian
and less liberal than virtually all of
us had expected but it appears to me
that in the wake of that question we
have another question rising and that is
how stable is really this system if you
look up on the basic characteristics as
you said now it is a very narrow core
power base that he has over his KGB
friends from st. Petersburg and it's
also very negative selection we all
remember Andrei Amalric the essay will
the Soviet Union survive the until my
early collapse in 1984 and his main
argument was the very negative selection
under the Brezhnev regime this is the
rather more negative selection that we
are seeing now and indeed that President
Putin on the one hand wants to
centralize all power on the other hand
he doesn't want strong decision makers
that's a contradiction in fact the
natural result of such limited
decision-making capacity is that you get
government paralysis which seems to be
what we are seeing now in virtually all
areas apart from political reform which
seems to be the priority area and this
also means if better the government
can't really do anything to accommodate
any anybody
and Putin's priority now seems to be to
set up surrogate institutions like the
public chamber which reminds me a lot
about of garbage hopes presidential
council more and more Advisory Council
less the less decision-making compass
which and the more power to informal
institutions while taking away the power
from the formal institutions this
normally doesn't work very well and in
the end what I hear that
pootis businesses now are told is that
the only real political capital is the
president's personal popularity such a
system does not become very stable and I
should add an aspect here right now I
would argue that in Ukraine we're
clearly seeing the greatest democratic
breakthrough since the August 91 in
performance of Julian and in this
contrast of course Putin's endeavors
look all the worse and mosque is a
wonderful place that get utterly bored
with whatever it has a thought half a
year earlier and wants to have a new
thought with a nature of mind which is
very similar to New York three alia so
my suspicion is that this regime is
really much less stable and therefore
also less harmful than we usually think
would be if you could respond to those
two questions and then let it open up a
discussion
whether Roscoe is Bella now that it was
an effort has brought out the right
occasion
I think it may be unfortunately more
sacrifices by by family and impersonal
sleep patterns that I think that explain
doing it now although there is an
interesting phenomenon instantly which
does relate perhaps to the decline in
general international news interests
perhaps in Russia you know my
competition was a perhaps a little bit
more restricted than at previous times
because I'm it seems to be a lot of the
American media and the international
media now use Moscow much more as a sort
of way station to the the latest stands
where there's some sort of conflict
taking place they've become much more
firemen and it's true that we are seeing
sort of post post-soviet downsizing of
the priority giving to Russia and Russia
specific news amongst the Western press
corps at least in terms of yes you would
talk about also the dish in ski
portrayed the other anecdotes that I
haven't yet printed at the book but I
will there were a few months ago the
Kremlin had a website where it had
various some questions for children
about you know MultiChoice ABC and D
what would you do children in the
following situations you know and then
you can click to see what the president
answered and there was one question that
was some if two boys are fighting in the
schoolyard who you know what what's your
judgment you know the the one who loses
should be guilty the one who started it
should feel guilty both of them naughty
because you shouldn't start fighting and
the Putin option was you know I would
criticize the one who lost because
history never criticizes victors
I thought that was a pretty revealing
psychological comment as well
incidentally that's now been removed
from the Creveling websites in terms of
your your your two main points
corruption in the Kremlin I mean of
course it's terribly difficult to get
any objective analysis both even at the
survey level where I must say I think
most of the surveys I've seen a pretty
ropey methodologically or indeed
journalistically because you know the
Russians are pretty sophisticated at
hiding these things I think you know in
absolute cash terms
there's no doubted effective inflation
at the very least which means that the
the absolute amounts being seized are
much greater than they were in the past
and I would agree that the systems of
checks and balances have reduced
although they were never particularly
great shakes in the 90s either you know
one can think certainly of some examples
not only of yelps in hangovers in the
administration who have them continue to
operate should we say at the very least
conflicts of interests but also new
ministers promoted in Putin circle who
have some other interesting and
ambiguous commercial interests including
the telecoms minister there's a rather
interesting case taking place this week
in laughs British Virgin Islands on his
interest in various offshore trusts
linked to telecoms companies but it
seems to me the the Raymond cases are
quite interesting one actually because
it does touch on a sort of rather
pragmatic approach of Putin which seems
to be almost a sort of a merchant
banking style model if you like I'll let
my ministers continue to maintain their
commercial interests as long as they
also deliver to some degree on the
public policy line and I have to say I
think that the telecoms ministry has
been more effective than many and
actually pushing through restructuring
of the country's telecom sector
restructuring something like seventy
five regional fixed line operators into
just seven significant and much more
transparent companies and creating the
conditions for three national pretty
impressive and highly competitive mobile
telephone operators again albeit
possibly with the minister having a
commercial interest in one of them and
that says something perhaps about again
the question of the limited tools that
Putin has to work with and the limited
tools that he himself has made himself a
victim of as well because clearly his
instincts are very much to trust only
those that he knows and has worked with
over a long period and given the nature
of the post-soviet era the collapse of
all of those traditional promotion
structures I think it's only in those
circumstances that someone like Putin
could have risen clearly
rapidly to a position of power names
let's not forget after all by Boris
Yeltsin and not someone who emerged
through some sort of political or
democratic process or a wide variety of
different jobs different functions
different parts of the country which
might have allowed him to develop a
broader base of acquaintances with a
wider range of skills so that even if
even if we assume that Putin himself is
relatively enlightened and non-corrupt
clearly he's had to make lots of
compromises for those that he's brought
with him perhaps haven't progressed so
far on the second question of
authoritarianism and stability yes I
mean clearly there are big questions for
the future about the the long term
perpetuation of the regime it seems to
me again coming back to the quality of
individuals that the biggest problem is
precisely that for all its faults in the
Soviet system there were some extremely
talented people who made it to the top
of the hierarchy within the Communist
Party and so on I'm not convinced that
that same degree of quality exists today
because clearly an awful lot of the best
and brightest if they've not emigrated
they've moved into the private sector
and they're not willing to play that
game so there's a an element of revolt
from perhaps the second grade group of
individuals who are now getting promoted
to top positions
I'm not sure though whether we're going
to see any rapid move to instability it
seems to me that you know money counts
for an awful lot in modern Russia and
compared with the chaos of the 1990s and
the undoubted you know reduction vast
reduction living standards for many
ordinary Russians you know it's no
surprise that Putin's popularity is so
high it may not be so much due to him as
despite him but the fact is with oil
prices where they are and that kind of
whole post-soviet economic restructuring
continuing it seems to me that people
are willing to make a lot of compromises
as long as they can continue to live
fairly comfortably or see some prospects
of personal improvement in their own
lives
I certainly
last don't see any great signs that the
younger generation of Russians is
becoming politically active or critical
of the regime when I looked at the the
exit polls for putin's reelection this
spring for example it was striking that
the highest proportion who voted for
putin was the youngest age categories
and that applied equally in the
parliamentary elections for united
russia last year as well so at least in
those broad macro terms I don't see any
great sign that the younger generation
is focusing on any sort of alternative
political project that's of course
partly an issue of the failures of the
liberal alternatives the SPS and yeah
blocker and so on which have also failed
to perhaps deliver in a way that a newer
generation might have found attractive
but it doesn't seem to suggest in any
case that there's a great will from
below there's also a kind of it seems to
me a failure an inability a lack of
comfort to inter mediate between the
political elites the Kremlin and those
on the streets and that's ironically
sometimes perhaps can lead to slightly
more democratic outcomes than we might
expect you know I remember when
pensioners went on the streets and
Verona as a couple of years ago to
object to initial attempts to introduce
communal reforms to cut subsidies on
electricity and phone bills and so on
pretty quickly
the Kremlin the government withdrew
those projects so it seems to suggest at
least thank God at this stage they're
not willing to revoke revert to more
hard-line authoritarian moves or force
to actually push through change we saw
it again this summer with the
monetization of social benefits or again
there are a lot of modifications and
delays after some degree of popular
protest so perhaps you know the
situation isn't quite as rigid or as
tense as we you know sometimes might
imagine but clearly there are some
challenges for the future in the
sustainability of this system it seems
to me number one obviously is the
succession and the closer we get to 2008
how if not Putin himself then certainly
many of those around him particularly
if they have enriched themselves we'll
be thinking about how to preserve those
games and that is bound to lead to some
degree of internal struggle if there's
no fight from the outside to ensure that
if not Putin then a acceptable consensus
replacement for him goes in and tries to
preserve those existing privileges and
there are a number of other factions but
I just cite that of Chechnya which it
seems to me is a very worrying cancer
that spreading far beyond the region to
the entire nature of Russian society and
it's unfortunately I think almost
inevitable in the current situation
we're going to see repetitions of bedlam
which at some stage must start to
explode onto the broader political arena
and question the policy that's currently
being pursued
thank you yes sir let us open up and
please talk into the microphones all the
time because we have c-span here Jim
Collins Andrew I would like you to
address one one question I think it's
sort of an article of faith in the West
to a very great extent that genuine
entrepreneurship has to have an
environment which is based on
predictability rule of law and so forth
and also that this is really the only
long-term sustainable engine of growth
what you're suggesting here is that
we're far from that and that Putin is in
some sense setting up a system which is
not based on those premises and
therefore is there a contradiction
between his admittedly successful
restructurings so far which are in the
main major industry restructurings but
more broadly a contradiction between his
style of rule and what he's doing and
the cultivation of entrepreneurship
which got to be an engine of growth yes
really yes I mean now he seems to me
there is a fundamental contradiction
again you know it's dangerous of course
to idealize the 90s and it seems to me
that you know very oftenly the shift
that we're seeing for or away from rule
of law and predictability is is not
terribly great the vector is negative
but clearly there wasn't an awful lot as
to the
your predictability in the 90s when we
look at some the legal system for
example the paradoxes it seems to me is
that Putin's top priority perhaps in the
first term was precisely to try to
create some degree of predictability and
stability after the uncertainty of the
Yeltsin years and I think that probably
in many ways was one of his greatest
achievements that along with them
you know some degree of fiscal
responsibility albeit with the kind of
the benefit of oil prices to help him
but certainly individual cases like
Yukos have done nothing to help send a
message that courts and laws are most
important it seems to me the one of the
reasons this Yukos thing is dragging on
so long is that nobody government
officials bureaucrats judges prosecutors
tax inspectors and so on are willing to
take the final decision they're all
waiting for some degree of decision from
above and so that process not only on
the high national scale is sending out a
sign of instability and unpredictability
but it's also sending out the green
light to regional administration's and
other government officials around the
country to reinstate that sort of
personality based of a true form of
implementation of law as I say I mean I
think that there is still under gray
underlying dynamism in the Russian
economy some of the surveys at least
that you look at by entrepreneurs argue
that corruption or the influence of the
state is not now their top concern
seeming to suggest that perhaps
competition and other slightly healthier
factors are it's certainly something
that Russian entrepreneurs have got used
to but again I think I'd come back to my
initial concluding point about that
whole question of missed opportunities
really there is still some growth but
precisely because at the end of the
second of the first Putin term he's
destroyed a lot of that initial
stability and predictability that he
first created we're seeing missed
opportunities and really things could be
much better if there was a little bit
more of a symbolic move towards
institutions and not people
Martin Walker Andrew I was wondering
what role pluralism might play in your
analysis I was rather confused when you
were talking about media control and the
NTV operation not having worked out
quite as perhaps couldn't have intended
and I wasn't clear whether you were
suggesting that now it was under the
control of Gaza from other corporate
groups whether this represented a kind
of pluralism which might be seen as some
sort of check upon upon Putin's personal
power or whether you were saying
something altogether different it would
seem to me that what we what we've seen
over the last two or three years is is
that the room for and the roots of
further pluralism have been a bit of any
widget yes no minor point on NTV was
that I was arguing even if you know it
may not be the case that Putin wanted
NTV to essentially become yet another a
third state control channel I remember
the negotiations that took place and at
the time that the government was trying
to wrest NTV from Kaczynski's control
there were negotiations with other
businessman including Ted Turner George
Soros and so on I'm not sure the Kremlin
would have permitted that but I think
Kaczynski and others were also amongst
those who were blocking that process and
so potentially an opportunity was missed
not simply because of the Kremlin's
desire to nationalize all media but also
because others involved in the process
were pushing their own commercial or
political agendas and the result was
maybe worse than the initial intention
but clearly particularly in terms of the
as I said the federal television
stations there's no doubt in my mind
that the degree of diversity has
suffered hugely over the past four years
that said NTV still does take us
slightly more slightly different lines
should we say than the two others are TR
and OSA the first channel in particular
which is which is a fast frankly of
first ten minutes showing Putin meeting
whichever governor or a head of state or
visiting a factory regardless of the
news value NTV takes a slightly more
aggressive line but it seems to me it's
becoming a little bit you know like they
used to talk about
hi park under socialism from Detroit -
and a Gazeta
you know it's sort of a little bit of a
steam valve that allows some symbolic
quasi independence whereas in reality
again on Chechnya or other sensitive
matters the editorial line is still
pretty restrained and self-censorship if
not direct censorship from above has
come back before what is this I don't
see any question Peter right away thanks
very much usually George Washington
University I enjoyed your your talk you
if I could summarize some of it you use
the phrase liberal or enlightened
authoritarianism as a way of
characterizing Putin's rule and you
quite rightly are quick to raise two
questions will it continue to be at
least relatively enlightened and
secondly and my mind more important can
it actually be implemented in any
effective way and let me just give my
response as a member of this audience I
I don't know whether it would be the
same after reading the whole book
everything you've said to me today let
me start the other way nothing you've
said today suggests me that it can be
expected that the enlightened
authoritarian goals that you try to
define some extent I didn't hear
anything in your talk boots that gave
any reason to think why they could be
successfully implemented on the contrary
it seems to me that overwhelming thrust
of your talk was but they could not be
and
and you use well Unferth ii went on to
say that as you see it in Putin's
policies there's a lot of what you might
almost call inevitability about those
those policies but he is your phrase was
he has virtually no room for manoeuvre
that he's somehow he's in tune with the
times he's in tune to a considerable
extent with public emotions and feelings
and therefore has a high political
rating therefore no room for manoeuvre
therefore there's a certain quality of
inevitability about a lot of his
policies I would agree with a lot of
that and the general thrusts that and I
just like to ask you sort of following
on from that to comment on my own very
broad analysis and see whether you agree
with it it seems to me that the sort of
almost defining characteristic of the
regime in Russia today is that it
represents the interests of elite groups
that exist up here and then there is a
horizontal divide and very little in the
way of the middle class in a real sense
and then the rest of the mass of the
population and what happened on the
altar was that the people who supported
Yeltsin particularly oligarch on the
Garko groups they as it were ruled the
roost for a number of years then when
Putin came in a different section of
those elites said we didn't get off
their cut in those years under Yeltsin
we now want our fare cut and that group
is predominantly in the so-called
special services and so what we've seen
in the conflict the political conflicts
we've seen over the last four years have
primarily been conflicts within the
elite between the previous groups
favored under the Yeltsin regime and
this new elements these new elements
coming under Putin and those conflicts
have been quite sharp and and I think
will continue in the future
and they because they exist within a
regime that doesn't have a foundation in
popular support I think that it does
actually make the regime much more
potentially unstable than then you
tended to suggest so and then just final
point
gurgi Satara Forman articles I'm sure
you read had a very interesting one
recently in which he thought that it was
actually less likely than more likely
the Putin would survive until 2008 and
his you is that now there is a third
element within the elite that wants its
share of the pie and will demand it and
cause further conflicts Nene and that is
the military and he sees that as a
unsafe a destabilizing element within
this regime so you have Jostein
conflicting competing elements within
this narrow elite then a huge divide
between it and the rest of society and I
would argue as as a tariff dose that
this is actually potentially very
unstable arrangement sorry to be long
way thank you very much better I think
that those were very valid points and I
think that this is very much the
critical part of a debate and if I may
here I'm the you mentioned satara's
who's the person who's normally knows
where one should be in the political
spectrum and he's know shortly opposing
another these people who's always right
in the middle
Sergey Cara ganas came out recently in
risque gas yet away the sharp criticism
of Russia's policy towards Belarus then
you suspect that something is not as it
should and must get canceled Moritz the
Moscow tabloid now seems to have a
sharpest criticism against the Putin so
it seems that we are seeing opposition
in places that we would not expect and
therefore we do not quite look up on
this end
yes thanks thanks for coming first of
all I I don't think I'd use the word
enlightened or Theret area so I
definitely don't like that I I might
talk about soft authoritarianism I think
but well then I withdraw it so it can it
can it be implemented
um yeah well difficult um I think one of
the I think one of the kind of the
skills or the cynical tactics of the
Putin regime is that their or maybe it's
the nature of you know Byzantium there
are these constants and contradictory
signs which do make it very often quite
difficult to see the underlying trend
you know and so there are clearly some
things that look very negative on the
other hand you know there are some more
positive things I mean I can think of a
number of individuals within the Kremlin
administration for example who I think
are relatively enlightened who do
definitely have a reformist agenda they
want to pursue who don't see any
attractiveness of a rising influence and
the sort of the so-called hardliners or
celebrity so it seems to me you know
we're certainly seeing compared with
five years ago a rise in influence of
some of those hide line forces but I
don't think we've yet seen the kind of
the purging of the others and nor have
we seen Putin making as it were a final
decision in favor of one over over the
other one example might be you know this
Gazprom merger with Rosneft for example
which I think there are many different
interpretations as always but you could
see it is actually a something of a
humiliation of the mysterious section
for example who was only named a few
months ago to chair Rosneft and now is
going to again lose his position it
seems being subsumed into this broader
giant that looks perhaps like in that
particular case perhaps Putin siding
with Medvedev and Miller against him for
instance so I think the signals are a
bit ambiguous can authoritarianism work
more generally well I think it's
certainly quite interesting to look at
the amount of time especially of Anders
but how much time Putin looks at
Kazakhstan these days you know I mean I
think by pretty much all objective
measures one would have to say
Kazakhstan is much more authoritarian
than Russia but clearly economically
doing extraordinarily well and those
same sort of transmission mechanisms for
bringing about
market reformer that should be much more
effective you know if you look at
banking reform communal reform
development of mortgages as well as the
kind of the whole process of
privatization and restructuring of the
natural monopolies it's gone much
further you know that's even before we
talked about in a cases like China or
Singapore or whatever that you hear
circulating sometimes in the ruling
elite so at least in terms of the vision
maybe to some degree in terms of the
culture of near neighbors you know there
is some prospects that the model in
theory could be sustainable and
certainly one that people are looking at
in terms of terms of your analysis of
the elites and so on I would certainly
agree that this you know I think it was
very zosky who once said you know only a
thousand people matter in Russia really
and certainly that was very much one of
his priorities in the manipulation of
ideas and the delivery of policies
clearly there's no middle classes we
would recognize it in the West by income
levels and I think one of the kind of
saddest and most worrying things for
Russian society is that there
nonetheless is a middle class by level
of values and those people of course are
the ones who've been deeply humiliated
and destroyed over the past 15 years you
know the teachers the lawyers the
doctors all of those who really did have
some sort of sense of values that could
be locked into perhaps by a more
enlightened political elite but instead
of you know given up their training and
their careers to become taxi drivers or
shuttle traders or to move into
something entirely different and that's
created a huge problem also for the
current not only the current but the
next generation it seems to me in terms
of recreating a more modern and
effective state and that could obviously
be a be an area for conflict again going
back to the exit polls that I've seen
you know if one looks at the success of
the raja'na motherland' party more
nationalistic it was again there that it
looked as there are a lot of those sort
of disillusioned middle-class voters of
a kind of below retirement age were
turning away from the Communists but
also away from United Russia so
potentially there are some zones of
conflict there and yet to pick up on
your your final points about the
military and so on I would agree I mean
I again
in the caucuses a couple of weeks ago in
Armenia and Azerbaijan and Georgia I
mean you know everything is relative but
it's the nearest part of Russia it seems
to me - a sort of military coup frankly
and I think it's much more the Army and
the security services that are
controlling both the borders and the
politics and the trade in those zones
the military places the frozen conflicts
and so on than it is the Kremlin
directly and that's a big worry just on
the final point of other elites who are
criticizing and I think that clearly is
right and it's clearly a worry the only
thing I have to say that you know we
have to cut somewhat separate is that
there's also a you know a sort of
sociological phenomenon which is that we
are seeing the final purging from power
and influence of those intellectual
elites of the 1990s and while
objectively intellectually that in
itself is worrying it does also perhaps
to some degree color their own extremely
negative judgments at the moment as
they've been excluded from the zone of
power which is all with danger Nikolai
zlobin yes thank you
any guys loving center for defense
information when Putin spoke after this
lon on Russian TV
he said the Soviet Union couldn't
survive and then he said unfortunately
it was very dramatic short speech but he
uses what unfortunately when he talked
about Soviet Union and when we met with
him in Nigeria and what I was in this
group of people materials put in an oval
area well this topic
unfortunately Soviet Union doesn't exist
anymore was quite often in his words
after almost four hours sitting with him
I came out he was very impressed I
should admit he was very impressive but
I came out with a very clear idea that
putting his very strong solid Dogma in
his head
everything is very very like stick
together
Yukos human human rights freedom of
media George West and by the way I
wouldn't give him a lot of credit for
being
because he said such an outrageous
thinks about the Western political
culture so vulgar so simple so just
unbelievably wrong so I think it has
very wrong picture about the West but my
question is when I came out with this
are clear pictures that Putin has very
very strong dog'll in his head when
everything is when everything nothing
contradict each other every every part
is there in the right place in his head
I realized it's and it's impossible to
argue with him on every particular
aspect of this situation Russian economy
or human rights each now because
everything is stick to each other and my
question to was to myself and now I'm
asking this question to you is that
there is anybody who can challenge
entire dogma
there is anybody who can come up with
completely not to argue on little things
let's do differently I think in Chechnya
all let's give more freedom to a middle
class or something like that but to come
up with something very different to
Putin's Russia another concept of Putin
Putin's Russia another concept of Russia
inside Russia is anybody who can you
think can do it or outside because you
know Washington is suffering this
equation should we do anything can we do
anything what we can do because things
going wrong
etc but I feel my feeling is very clear
that if we cannot come up and challenge
him on a big scale it's pointless to
argue Samsung secondary Samsung
secondary so this is my question thank
you yes I mean I I remember in August
2000 when just after the Kursk and if
you remember Putin went up finally to
speak to the relatives and he was pretty
savagely criticized and his response was
you can blame me for what I've done in
the past few months but you can't blame
me for what's happened in the past 15
years and I think you know no surprise
15 years and drop off you know from then
on effectively you know Gorbachev and it
was downhill to the end so I mean I
agree I but I think there is a sort of a
world view and I have to say that you
know economic growth oil price driven on
the one
and and quite cynical and somewhat
inconsistent series of messages from the
West rail apology k-- moral equivalence
in human rights abuse near imperialism
and so on and just simply very mixed
messages from different representatives
of different governments at different
times has in many ways allow putin to
perpetuate i think that that mentality
and it's done very little to challenge
the sort of the global view do i see
anybody who can who can challenge it i
mean you know i think the starting point
has to be generational changed you know
i think i mean i today I still think
today that I'm much happier that we've
got a President Putin than a president
Primakov quite frankly you know I think
you know one could argue there were
certain aspects of public art that were
enlightened but I think you know and I
returned for a second tirade license you
know I don't believe in Sarah Terra's
arisen items but but no I mean I you
know I think all we can hope for is the
newer younger generation to some degree
in the future freed of those Soviets
complexes and legacy will think
differently but yeah I'm not sure yet
that I can see any individuals who come
into to fill that hole and nor do I see
much political space that's being
created by Putin to allow that to emerge
in Colin Andrew you answered part of the
question already about the middle class
but I still would like to come back to
it I grant you that the the Soviet
intelligentsia has come on hard times
I don't always regret that frankly
perhaps if you do but I do
raise the question about whether there
is not a new middle class emerging I
mean there are those who say that in
Moscow if you have a median family
income of a thousand then if it's
outside Moscow median family income of
between five hundred in that you are
middle-class and that this is a very
substantial group of people and that
they are people like small business
people property holders obviously some
of those who are the professionals and
so forth the question really is is you
know you I'm not sure you can just
dismiss this group and my really sort of
the question is how when are they going
to find or how do you think if possible
they will will find a means to express
themselves politically because at the
moment it's pretty clear they don't have
one yeah no I mean I agree they clearly
the economic growth of the past few
years has helped to create a middle
class by income levels certainly to some
degree and you know I remember I was
talking to some advisors in Kazakhstan a
few months ago who were arguing that you
know until you've got GDP per head of
5,000 dollars or something forget about
democracy you know and then beyond that
level property rights you know those
other sort of areas of vested interests
where there might be some scope for
coalescing certain sorts of middle-class
values could lead to a the growth of a
political movement if it's being
challenged by the current regime it just
seems to me that the as I say I D since
we what's been quite effective in in the
current Putin regime has been to two
separate personal individual liberties
you know Russians probably a kind of
freer in that sense in terms of income
levels the possibility of traveling of
watching the internet whatever than they
ever were before but it separated those
sorts of areas which could provide flash
points from political freedoms in any
more coherent or sort of Western
understanding of the sense
partly because perhaps of the failures
of the democratization of the 1990s so I
mean I suppose yes I think probably the
best hope one could have is that as that
middle class by incomes at least
increases there are some perhaps
financial vested interests that get
challenged and form the focus for for a
threat to the existing regime or the the
backwards moves that have been made in
terms of rule of law in the
institutionalization and just you know a
little bit more skeptical about in terms
of values whether the one is being at
the moment linked to the other salient
oblivion
just three quick points and first of all
and they thank you so much I personally
am a big fan of yours and I think we're
all so fortunate to have you in Moscow
for so long because your opinion about
things and Russia is probably by far the
most fair and always up to date so thank
you very much for your great coverage of
Russia just three quick things I wanted
to quickly run through first of all this
funny anecdote about Putin's
adoration of divinsky growing up in
Russia at that time not that I'm trying
to suggest knowing what we know today
that it was the greatest thing to do but
at the time we at school were actually
taught that your insky was a great hero
and there was this adoration list among
many boys who I knew at the time who are
not authoritarian today is just what we
knew about divinsky in many political
political readers of Russia at that time
then as we all know the rinsky's
monument was demolished and so there is
this transformation of mentality based
on the knowledge that we have certainly
thinking about the elections it is my
personal observation and I might be
absolutely wrong but my quick thinking
is that it's not always that whatever
Putin does is automatically as vicious
as there was the media portrays as we
know governor's particularly in some
regions have enormous power and when it
comes to presidential election I think
the use participates very actively and I
think it's kind of a little bit more
transparent process when it comes to
local government it's not as as
political but I think the oligarchs and
local business lid corrupts the regional
governments a lot and sometimes this
elections are just about how much money
local oligarchs or federal level or
oligarchs invest so you mentioned
something that that this really is doing
and I think basically his appointment of
people who he trusts who are well
educated I don't know I might
and suggest that maybe it's not always
that it's a bad thing when people are
appointment as opposed to elected
because when it comes to judges today
the last thing I heard them CNN before I
ran out was appointment of federal
judges in the United States so this is
something that I think we should think
about and lastly I think you absolutely
rightly pointed that interestingly it's
not always the level of democracy
corresponds to the speed of the economic
growth and when we benchmark Russia or
judge Russia we sometimes use different
yardsticks say for China for Latin
America and for Russia and when business
these people decide where to invest I
think they rely to a great extent on
what the economists and of course may be
firstly the Financial Times is writing
about it so how would you try to place
you know kind of bring this all together
if at all and see how can we kind of
judge Russia without double standards
and again I'm not suggesting that Russia
should be less democratic but there are
these gaps in consensus on how we judge
Russia and I think this is an issue yeah
thanks um in terms of yesterday gents
key and the Soviet past I mean it's a
point well taking and I quoted me in the
book from a man from Leningrad who was
saying that of course you know if you
talk about the the intellectual class in
Soviet times clearly the idea of joining
the KGB had a you know a very unpleasant
political connotation but for somebody
from Putin's background actually like
for many others it was simply a very
pragmatic way of getting ahead the
perhaps the it certainly in terms of you
know Putin's background and his
personality and so on it sort of fits in
very logically to that pattern and
unfortunately the result particularly
reinforced by this very rapid elevation
that he had to power and the economic
success of Russia over the past four
years has done unfortunately nothing to
to force him to challenge I think the
nature of that system and the faults of
in a way that has happened to too many
other Russians but but I think is a much
broader process I'm now begin my whole
book talking about the ambiguities are
coming to terms with the Soviet past and
it just seems to me there's still been
in Russia nothing like you know the
process that's necessary of looking at
the the problems of the Soviet era sort
of continued adoration of Stalin in so
many quarters and so on and that is a
worrying trend in terms of the governors
I set yeah i II certainly there's no
doubt that there's a huge degree of
corruption and clearly resistance to
Moscow's imposition of policy of the
regional level I do actually think
though there the bezel and the post
bedlam political reforms weren't
entirely spurious you know there was a
connection to the North caucuses in
particular and I think there is a
genuine belief probably with more than a
little reason in the Kremlin that some
of the governance structures of the
North Caucasus particularly North
Ossetia are hugely corrupt with a vast
degree of manipulation between the
regional elites the the police the
military the security services and so on
and so one can sort of understand a
desire and a need to go beyond that
although one has to say you know what
was Putin doing in the first four years
when essentially all of those military
and police structures were supposed to
be pretty tightly under federal control
it seems to me that Beslan is a sort of
you know regrettable parody of the
failures of this new system I mean how
is it possible he could send down you
know his interior minister his head of
internal security presumably his very
close long-standing friend Sergei Ivanov
in charge of the army all of them
apparently incapable of doing anything
to create to avoid the total chaos and
lack of coordination on the ground that
took place around that school forgetting
about the how we got there in the first
place and you know is it by total chance
ours myself that the kind of the the
last relatively democratically elected
real leader in the region a chef who was
ousted of course by Putin in favor of a
KGB crony was the only one who seemed to
have the acceptable degree of legitimacy
locally and the
little courage and personal strength of
character to go in and actually save
some people it seems to me that has to
be a huge indictment of the way the
system's going so yes local regional
elites terribly corrupting and efficient
but frankly do we try to replace them
with an even more opaque and arguably
more corrupt in an effective federal one
of the local level not sure it'll work
foreign direct investment and so on yes
I mean I clearly I suppose the Western
media has some influence in in
determining perceptions but frankly you
know when an Exxon or a shell goes into
Russia you know there are big boys and
they go in knowing the risks and of
course also having the benefit of
substantial political support which
means they can circumvent a lot of the
the conditions that exist for ordinary
investors but I mean I do think the fact
that foreign direct investment you know
which is probably quite an important
litmus test of the investment climate
not so much as the perception climate in
Russia the fact that it is relatively
low is revealing of course you know
compared with China Russia has a much
smaller country the market reforms and
property rights in particular much less
well established and so on so it's no
surprise that we're still at an earlier
stage and that FDI could grow but I
think it does probably reflect quite
accuracy the continued level of concerns
on the other hand I agree compared with
China for example one of the ironies of
modern Russia is that it is despite the
setbacks of the past few years still a
much more open society you know one
knows about corruption in Russia partly
because it gets reported in the media
within Russia let alone abroad you know
which is much more the case so it seems
to me I don't know very well but
compared with China for example thank
you last question Dimitri penury of the
Embassy of Belarus
thank you very much banana roof embassy
Belarus some time ago I during a similar
discussion I said something like this
that the very of Russia becoming a
strong democracy because in this case it
would cut off oil and gas and all other
raw materials lavish flow that is going
down to the west together with the
capital by the way and it would use it
to create
it's owned a strong state and maybe do
the context further on to influence its
influence so my question is essentially
putting aside this locus of democracy
human rights and so on and so forth what
is the real choice of the West would be
a strong Russia or Russia of the kind is
now the weak and that maybe not reliable
upon especially but this at least gives
no trouble thank you it's not an I agree
if Russia would be a democracy amidst
you we might have had that image
Aronofsky as foreign minister at the
time of September 11th who's advocating
support for the Taliban and it's true
that there are some very dangerous
undercurrent so it seems to me that if
we are to move towards a more democratic
society is some sort of abstract goal in
Russia then it has to be a process
that's very carefully thought-out so you
know step by step but what can I say is
will bynum prefer a strong or a weak
Russia well I mean I think if some you
know I still think compared with an
awful lot of Russia's neighbors
particularly in Central Asia you know
we've got a more attractive choice now
than any of the alternatives and as I
used a phrase in my book you know it
seems to me the kind of Russia today's
is way beyond the the dreams of Russian
citizens in the in the 1980s let's say
you know it probably has disappointed
somewhat on the on the hopes of the
early 90s but actually it's a probably a
fairly realistic place for it to be now
at the turn of the new millennium
thank you very much Andrew and we wish
you the best of last year during your
book Lawrence
[Applause]
and rujak is Moscow bureau chief for the
Financial Times in